Graduates from evil medical school have long
dreamed of sharks with frickin' laser beams
on their heads; but when they moved into their
first volcano fortress they were disappointed
sharks couldn't survive there…
OR CAN THEY.
80 percent of volcanic eruptions likely happen
under water; even on the ocean floor, volcanoes
produce explosions and molten lava, even though
there's high-pressure, and it's verrrry cold.
The National Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
reports the Pacific flood West Mata volcano
spews water that's akin to the acidity somewhere
between battery and stomach acid.
And yet, some shrimp were spotted living nearby.
Volcanoes may be deadly, but are considered
rich environments because of ample bacteria,
minerals and warmth.
During a survey in 2012 of the volcanically
active Kermadec Ridge by New Zealand's National
Institute of Water and Atmospheric Research,
scientists found rainbow colored Polychaete
(polly-keet) Worms, sometimes called bristle
worms.
They've got extending, protruding jaws like
an H.R. Geiger wet dream… they're creeptastic.
Because of the rarity of undersea exploration,
scientists often discover new species once
they get down there; like the Crown Jellyfish,
spotted 5000 feet below the surface (1500M).
This unidentified species uses its long tentacles
to sweep for bioluminescent zooplankton.
So weird.
On another expedition in 2009, Oregon State
University researchers explored new species
around a highly active volcano near Guam.
They found "shrimp, crab, limpets and barnacles,"
and one of them, the Loihi shrimp, has "tiny
claws like garden shears" which allow it to
graze on bacterial filaments.
They also found a species of shrimp that preys
on things killed by the noxious plumes emanating
from these mouths of hot volcanic death.
Obviously, when the volcano erupts, the animals
have to flee, but the benefits outweigh the
costs.
This is why most of the animals that live
near volcanoes are small, crabs, shrimp, worms
and coral.
Evolutionarily, they can take that risk, but
a large animal?
That's hot.
Pacific Sleeper sharks are normally found
in the North Pacific from Japan to Mexico,
and are generally sluggish, sleepy sharks.
They're considered non-aggressive and live
really deep, so they're difficult to see.
But in July a team from National Geographic
was taking video of the Kavachi volcano and
found two species of shark hanging out inside
the volcano's caldera.
The researchers freaked because Kavachi erupted
two dozen times in the 20th century, including
twice in the least 15 years!
It's considered one of the most active volcanos
in the Southwest Pacific, and yet, 12 miles
from the deadly volcano… there were these
sluggish sharks!
The water would be far hotter, and more acidic
than they normally could handle, and it raises
more questions than answers.
If confirmed, they would be the furthest south
they'd ever been seen, and it begs the question:
how can these sharks survive in such an extreme
environment.
I haven't said this in a few weeks, so bear
with me.
More reasaearch is nedeed.
More shark research?
Yes, please!
Sharks are jawsome.
Do you have any ideas why a shark would want
to live near a volcano?
At this point, your guess is might be as good
as
the scientists'.